Speaker 1: you want to get on with me today,
your nickname in the waiting lobby should
be your name and where you are calling from
nicknames. And this sort of thing will will
not get you on just so everybody knows. Let's
go next to Evan from Las Vegas, Nevada. Evan,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Hi, David. Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. I was wondering.
Speaker 4: Your opinion about when we heard
Josh SHAPIRO speech, I think it was last week,
which was a great speech. Yeah, I thought he
made a great point about like how Republicans have
kind of become even though they claim to be this
Freedom Party, they're really the anti Freedom
Party. They're against abortion. They're against,
you know, teaching theories that they might
agree with. They're against parents deciding
with their kids what they want to do with
a doctor, etc.. Do you expect Democrats to
kind of use that talking point more? Because
I personally think it's a great talking point.
Speaker 1: I think absolutely the case is
I think it absolutely is the case that it
should be used. Listen, they love talking about
freedom and yet they want to take freedom away
from you in schools, in your bedroom, at
your doctor's office and on and on and on.
And I think I think it makes absolutely perfect
sense. It breach. It sort of straddles economic
and social issues. They want to take away
your freedom to organize a union, if that's
what you want to do. You know all these things.
I think you know your freedom to shop around for
prescription drugs or insurance or whatever the
case may be. I think it's an excellent talking
point. I'm not really like a focus group
guy, so I think the experts need to do some
brainstorming and sort of figuring out the exact
right way to do it. But I think absolutely 100%.
Speaker 4: Great. Yeah, no, I've used that
just interpersonally with friends that maybe
not aren't like crazy Trumpists, but I
have some friends who are like, you know,
kind of in the middle. Yeah. And it seems to
click. I mean, they're at least they don't have
a good argument against it, you know?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Because it's
the truth. That's the reality. The
the arguments work way. You know,
Republicans have made pretty good headway with
arguments that are lies, but arguments that
are the truth, I think, work even better.
Speaker 4: Exactly. Okay. Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you, my friend,
very much. Appreciate hearing from you